Been sharing
with you and our
viewers throughout the morning
about this note.
Investigators say
they obtained from that
43 year old shooter
our very own John Miller
spoke with a law enforcement official
who was close to the investigation
who says this note was two pages
and the 43 year old started the note
with an introduction saying
his name was Anthony McCray.
He also goes on to say,
I will be shooting up MSU.
And he says another team
will finish the city of Lansing.
But that's not all.
There are also targets in that note.
So it's unclear
if the members of law enforcement
that we hear from any moment
we'll talk about these targets.
We do know one target was a warehouse,
the other
an employment agency,
a discount store and a church.
As you can imagine,
all of this is difficult for folks
who are still coping with
what happened here
Monday night,
alumni who returned to the campus
for homecoming,
some saying, myself included,
never thought they would be
back on campus to cover a mass shooting.
John Miller is here with us now.
So in terms of that note,
I think it's interesting that
he said maybe,
maybe there's a motive and what we saw,
but we can't confirm anything just yet.
We know what some of the words were
in that note.
We know that there were locations.
How do you, though,
based on your experience,
how do you read that note?
Well, in the note,
he makes himself out to be a victim.
He lists 12 targets.
He claims to be in charge of
a team of 20 shooters.
You know, I talked
to Mary Ellen
O'Toole, the renowned former FBI profiler
who said
that's not unusual for a person
who is a loner, who's a nobody
to want to create this
this note, this aura
that would give him power and create fear
if he went on to hit one
or more of these targets
and left that note saying
there's this army of 20
and I'm in command of it.
But other parts of the note,
people hate me.
They made me what I am today, a killer.
No one noticed me.
Why do they hate me?
I am a person So he's feeling isolated.
He's feeling alone.
He's very angry.
And when you consider
that he did the shooting escape,
the scene intended to escape the scene
and had a potential list of a dozen
other targets
where he held some grudge
against each one of these places,
the employment agency
the store, the fast food place, the
the church
and and eight magazines
fully loaded with nine
millimeter ammunition, two guns,
50 other bullets.
There's a good possibility,
a good possibility
that he intended to carry forth
more shootings
until he was until he was captured.
One important note
I want to make sure you said
in the note
it mentions
I have a team of 20 important
that we did just learn
and they confirmed
in this update that they do
believe he was acting alone
there was no
but just for people
who are just joining us there was no
there is there is no team of 20.
This is part of his part of his attempt
to make himself larger than he is.
And and all of those places
were visited by police
who said you were mentioned in this
you were mentioned in this letter
there is no threat
and there is no team of 20.
But John asking at the same time
what is the connection
if any that you might have had to
this individual Right.
John, it's often following
mass shootings like this.
So we learned that
the guns were purchased
legally, though they noted
they were not registered.
He did have multiple encounters
with police prior.
It seemed mostly for traffic situations
although they mentioned an arrest in 2019
for a concealed carry of a weapon
based on current law.
Should he have been able
to buy
a gun legally after an encounter
like that.
Apparently.
And there's two sets of laws here.
One is he
he had to pass the next check
the federal background check
to make sure he wasn't a convicted
felon wasn't
the subject
of any domestic violence
order of protection.
But then in Michigan separately
you have to apply to the state police
give your information
they have to do a separate background
check to make sure
that there are no prohibitive encounters
with law enforcement.
And because, Jim,
he was not a convicted felon,
arrested on a felony, pled that down
to a misdemeanor,
was sentenced to probation.
He was actually
with a limited criminal background,
still qualified to buy those two weapons.
The nine millimeter high point
and a Taurus C, three
semiautomatic pistols.
And that other than they say
from that
from that arrest,
it's still in their possession
of the linking. Right. They still are.
As ridiculous as it sounds, Erica,
part of his sentence was that
he had to forfeit the illegal gun
to the police department
as part of his plea agreement.
John Miller, always appreciate it.
Thank you.